[Music]
they can't all be air bud hey
maybe you quit feeding your dog tacos
he'd have better eyesight my insensitive
staff found this video hysterical it's
animal cruelty as far as I'm concerned
so I challenged them to see if they
could do any better
[Music]
this is definitely the wrong way to eat
a Reese's chocolate and peanut butter a
classic combination is that Eagle Eye
cherry I've been a long time since save
tonight all right enough with the
foreplay now slather some on your dong
that guy makes a healthy snack thank you
that reminds me my mom used to make the
best ants on a log and she'd hold the
raisins because I don't like raisins or
peanut butter and then she put a side of
ranch out there were some buffalo wings
goofy dance on the log you mind your
goddamn business that woman is a saint
next girls transition will be complete
on the premiere of I am canine
how about we meet my parents another
time is it just me or does Vanessa have
resting bitchface I was gonna paint
myself like my dog but my dog's face is
mostly black and I thought wow it is all
worth it when she gets to fly under the
plane for free I did it as Hollywood
makeup artist he used to come to bed all
done up like that looks like someone had
a couple of beers passed out watching
Animal Planet
his owner must be an ugly
now draw a red rocket on his face for
getting up on the furniture I know what
he's dreaming about
[Music]
yeah I miss my balls too lost them in a
tea bagging accident when I worked at
the Container Store don't want to talk
about it this is just what happens after
you sniff out one too many heroin bust
no drop it drop it
yeah you can share that because dog
needles are cleaner than human needs
please respect that dog fighting is a
big part of my culture tonight's
undercard brought to you by cute dog
fighting calm in the black and white
coat I have an EZ Pass in the beautiful
honey brown coat also have a tease ever
the two dogs fighting for the
championship tonight our brother and
sister
winner